- Bienvenue dans Comprendre l'information
et le calcul quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous et
je suis le directeur technique de IBM Quantum Education.
C'est la sixième leçon de la série et c'est la deuxième leçon de
la deuxième unité de la série, qui porte sur les algorithmes quantiques.
Dans la leçon précédente, nous avons discuté du modèle
de requête de calcul, et nous avons vu que dans ce modèle, les algorithmes quantiques peuvent
offrir un avantage remarquable
par rapport aux algorithmes classiques, notamment un avantage exponentiel dans le cas du problème de Simon.
Malheureusement, le modèle
de requête n'a pas vraiment de pertinence
pratique directe ou immédiate.
La notion de boîte noire est une
abstraction très utile comme on peut le constater, mais nous avons du travail à
faire si nous voulons appliquer
les enseignements que nous avons
tirés du modèle de requête à un cadre de calcul plus standard où les entrées sont données sous forme de chaînes de bits
plutôt que sous forme d'oracles ou de boîtes noires.
L'objectif principal de cette leçon est d'établir une base
à partir de laquelle nous pouvons faire ça.
Voici un aperçu de la leçon. Pour une grande partie de la leçon, nous allons nous concentrer
sur le coût de calcul,
ou en d'autres termes, à quel point différentes
tâches de calcul sont difficiles et comment on peut mesurer cette difficulté.
En gros, ça se traduit par combien de temps on doit attendre
que les calculs se terminent et finalement quels
problèmes de calcul
on peut résoudre et lesquels
sont hors de notre portée.
On va commencer par
quelques exemples. La factorisation entière et le calcul des plus grands communs
diviseurs ou PGCD en abrégé.
Ce sont de très bons exemples pour illustrer les
principes sous-jacents, et ils sont aussi tous les deux
très pertinents pour l'algorithme de Shor, dont on va
parler dans la prochaine leçon,
alors on va effectivement
tirer double profit de ces exemples.
Ensuite, on va discuter de la notion de coûts de calcul de façon plus générale et comment on peut la mesurer.
Il y a de nombreuses façons
différentes de faire ça, mais on va se concentrer assez
étroitement sur comment on peut faire ça avec des modèles de circuit de calcul,
plus précisément les Boolean circuits
et les quantum circuits.
L'accent sera mis ici sur les algorithmes plutôt que sur le matériel informatique,
par exemple, et on sera plus préoccupés
par la façon dont les coûts de
l'exécution d'un algorithme évoluent à mesure que les instances spécifiques du problème sur lesquelles il est exécuté grandissent en taille plutôt
que par le nombre de secondes,
de minutes ou d'heures que
requiert un calcul particulier.
L'idée qui motive ce point de vue est que les algorithmes ont une
importance fondamentale.
Encore aujourd'hui, on
exécute encore des algorithmes qui ont été développés il y a
très, très longtemps et très naturellement, ils vont être déployés
face à des instances de problèmes de plus en plus
grandes en utilisant du matériel plus rapide et plus fiable à mesure que la technologie se développe.
Et la façon dont ils évoluent nous dit beaucoup de choses
sur leur utilité et sur leur utilité future.
Dans la dernière section de la leçon, on va se tourner vers une tâche d'une importance capitale, qui est l'exécution de calculs classiques
sur des ordinateurs quantiques. La raison pour laquelle c'est important n'est pas parce qu'on espère remplacer les ordinateurs classiques
par des ordinateurs quantiques,
ce qui semble extrêmement improbable dans un avenir proche si jamais ça se produit, mais plutôt parce que ça ouvre
de nombreuses possibilités intéressantes
pour les algorithmes quantiques.
Plus précisément, une fois qu'on sait comment exécuter des calculs classiques
sur des ordinateurs quantiques, ils deviennent disponibles pour les algorithmes quantiques
en tant que sous-routines
donc on peut efficacement
exploiter tout ce qu'on sait sur les algorithmes classiques dans la poursuite d'avantages de calcul quantique.
Les ordinateurs classiques qu'on a aujourd'hui sont de véritables merveilles de la technologie.
Ils sont incroyablement rapides, mais pas au point qu'aucun problème de calcul
ne soit hors de leur portée.
Certains problèmes de calcul
sont si intrinsèquement difficiles que bien qu'on ait
des algorithmes pour les résoudre, aucun ordinateur sur la planète Terre aujourd'hui
n'est assez rapide pour exécuter ces
algorithmes jusqu'à leur conclusion sur des entrées même de taille modérée dans la durée de vie d'un être humain
ou même dans la durée de vie
de la Terre elle-même.
Pour mieux expliquer, regardons
le problème de la factorisation entière.
L'énoncé du problème est très simple. L'entrée du problème est un entier N d'au moins deux, et la sortie est la
factorisation en nombres premiers de N,
ce qui signifie une liste des facteurs de nombres premiers de N ainsi que les puissances auxquelles ces nombres premiers doivent être élevés
pour obtenir N en les
multipliant tous ensemble.
Bien sûr, on peut toujours multiplier les facteurs premiers ensemble dans n'importe quel ordre, mais mis à part leur ordre,
les factorisations en nombres premiers sont toujours uniques pour tout choix de N.
Ce fait s'appelle le
théorème fondamental de l'arithmétique, et si tu veux
en apprendre davantage à ce sujet, c'est quelque chose que tu peux trouver
au tout début de
nombreux livres sur la théorie des nombres.
Comme exemple très simple, voici la factorisation en nombres premiers
du nombre 12.
C'est deux à la puissance deux
fois trois à la puissance un.
WEBVTT
Sans surprise, un
ordinateur peut te dire ça en un clin d'œil en cherchant
de façon itérative des facteurs premiers.
Voici un autre exemple. Je ne vais pas essayer de lire ce nombre.
C'est environ 3,4 quattuordécillions, et je dois admettre que je trouve étrange qu'il y ait même un tel nom,
mais de toute façon, il a 46 chiffres décimaux et tu peux voir ici
sa factorisation en nombres premiers.
Un ordinateur peut aussi te dire ça. J'ai factorisé ce nombre en utilisant la méthode de factorisation incluse dans la bibliothèque de mathématiques symboliques
pour Python,
et ça a pris quelques secondes, ce qui n'est pas particulièrement long, mais il y avait un délai perceptible.
Et certainement la méthode factor N ne trouve pas cette factorisation en nombres premiers en cherchant naïvement des facteurs premiers.
Elle utilise en fait un hybride
de différents algorithmes, dont un appelé l'algorithme de la ligne colorée, qui est un algorithme de factorisation
plus sophistiqué que la recherche naïve et itérative
de facteurs premiers, et bien que ça puisse sembler
un assez grand nombre,
comme entrée d'un problème de calcul, ce n'est pas vraiment si grand que ça du tout.
Ce ne sont que 46 caractères.
Voici encore un autre exemple. C'est un nombre avec 309 chiffres décimaux.
Si on l'écrit en notation binaire, il a 1 024 bits et c'est
pourquoi il s'appelle RSA1024.
La factorisation en nombres premiers de ce nombre n'est pas connue actuellement.
Ce nombre vient du
défi de factorisation RSA, qui a été organisé par RSA
Laboratories de 1991 à 2007.
Ils offraient des prix en espèces
pour les factorisations en nombres premiers de divers nombres de taille croissante,
y compris celui-ci, qui valait 100 000 dollars américains,
mais ce prix n'a jamais été réclamé.
La sécurité du système
cryptographique à clé publique RSA est basée sur la difficulté
de la factorisation entière.
Si tu peux factoriser, tu
peux casser le système, et donc le but du défi était essentiellement de suivre l'état de l'art en matière de factorisation.
Le fait est que
factoriser ce nombre est au-delà de nos capacités actuelles.
Pour autant qu'on le sache, le
problème lui-même est trop complexe pour que les ordinateurs classiques
le résolvent en pratique.
Le plus grand nombre du défi RSA à avoir été factorisé jusqu'à présent, d'ailleurs, a 250 chiffres décimaux.
Il est peut-être un peu difficile
de lire ça sur l'écran, mais voici la factorisation en nombres premiers
de RSA250.
C'a été fait en 2020 à l'aide d'un algorithme connu sous le nom de crible algébrique des corps de nombres, et c'était un effort collectif impliquant des dizaines de milliers
d'ordinateurs dans le monde entier.
Maintenant, considérons un
problème de calcul différent, qui est le problème du calcul du plus grand commun
diviseur, ou PGCD en abrégé,
de deux entiers non négatifs.
Voici un énoncé du problème. L'entrée consiste en deux
nombres cette fois, N et M,
et on va supposer qu'ils
ne sont pas tous les deux égaux à zéro.
Le but est de calculer le
PGCD de ces deux nombres, qui est le plus grand entier D qui divise également N et M,
et si tu penses aux
factorisations en nombres premiers de N et M, tu trouveras que le PGCD est le produit de tous les nombres premiers
qui divisent à la fois N et M élevés au minimum des puissances qui apparaissent dans les deux
factorisations en nombres premiers.
Donc c'est lié au problème
de la factorisation entière, mais il s'avère être beaucoup, beaucoup plus facile
à résoudre pour les ordinateurs. On peut calculer les PGCD pour des nombres à plusieurs milliers de chiffres
en un clin d'œil.
C'est un peu inutile pour moi d'essayer de te montrer des exemples à l'écran parce qu'on pourrait remplir tout
l'écran de chiffres et on décrirait encore
des instances facilement résolues de ce problème.
Mais si tu es intéressé, suis le lien dans la description de la vidéo vers la page du manuel pour cette leçon et tu trouveras des cellules de code
pour les types de calculs
dont je parle, y compris ceux qui calculent
les PGCD de grands nombres, et tu peux les essayer toi-même.
La question est pourquoi est-il possible de calculer les PGCD si facilement ?
Et la réponse à cette question est qu'on a des algorithmes efficaces
pour calculer les PGCD.
Parmi eux se trouve l'algorithme d'Euclide, qui a été découvert il y a plus de 2 000 ans, mais il existe aussi d'autres
algorithmes de PGCD efficaces.
Et bien sûr on parle ici d'algorithmes classiques, donc ça amène une autre question.
Pourrait-il exister un algorithme classique efficace
pour la factorisation entière
qui nous permettrait de factoriser des nombres comme RSA1024
en un clin d'œil ?
Et la réponse est oui. Il pourrait absolument exister un algorithme classique efficace
pour la factorisation et actuellement on ne connaît aucun moyen
d'exclure cette possibilité. Tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on n'en a pas encore trouvé.
Pour tous les algorithmes classiques de
factorisation qu'on connaît, on cherche encore essentiellement
des facteurs
et ça met des nombres comme
RSA1024 hors de notre portée.
Les algorithmes efficaces de PGCD,
en revanche, ne fonctionnent tout simplement pas comme ça.
Ils ne cherchent pas un
plus grand commun diviseur. Ils le construisent effectivement avec une procédure mécanique dont le coût est à peu près comparable
à la multiplication des mêmes
deux nombres ensemble, et j'en dirai un peu plus à ce sujet plus tard dans la leçon.
WEBVTT
Bien sûr, tout ça prépare
l'algorithme de Shor, qu'on verra dans la prochaine leçon, qui est un algorithme quantique efficace
pour calculer les factorisations en nombres premiers, mais on a encore du chemin
à parcourir avant d'y arriver.
Ensuite, on va parler
d'un cadre mathématique grâce auquel on peut mesurer les coûts de calcul
de différents algorithmes,
y compris ceux dont on a déjà parlé.
Pour être clair, on va se concentrer très étroitement sur les circuits, ce qui n'est qu'une petite partie
d'un sujet beaucoup plus vaste.
Commençons par une vue de très haut niveau d'un calcul ordinaire
de la leçon précédente, ce qui signifie en particulier qu'on ne pense pas
aux problèmes de requête,
on pense à des
problèmes où l'entrée est donnée explicitement sous forme de chaîne binaire.
Comme je l'ai dit dans la leçon précédente, on pourrait bien sûr autoriser
d'autres symboles si on le voulait, mais restons simples et tenons-nous-en aux chaînes binaires
pour l'entrée et la sortie.
Le calcul lui-même pourrait être modélisé ou décrit de diverses façons, comme avec la machine de Turing
comme modèle de calcul,
les Boolean circuits, les quantum circuits, ou des programmes écrits dans
un langage comme Python ou tout autre langage de ton choix.
Comme je l'ai dit il y a un instant, on va se concentrer sur
les circuits, Boolean et quantiques.
D'abord, passons un peu plus de temps à parler de l'entrée et de la sortie, qu'on suppose être des chaînes binaires.
En utilisant des chaînes binaires, on peut encoder de nombreux types différents
d'objets mathématiques, comme des nombres, des vecteurs,
des matrices, des graphes,
des descriptions de molécules, par exemple, ainsi que des listes de tous ces objets et d'autres encore.
Comme exemple très simple, si on veut encoder des entiers non négatifs
sous forme de chaînes binaires, on peut utiliser la notation binaire.
Dans ce tableau, tu verras les 13 premiers
entiers non négatifs avec leurs représentations ou encodages
binaires.
Dans la troisième colonne, tu peux voir la longueur de
chacun de ces encodages, ce qui correspond au nombre total de bits nécessaires pour l'encodage,
et voici une formule simple qui te dit exactement combien de bits
sont nécessaires en général pour tout entier non négatif N.
Remarque en particulier que
la longueur de l'encodage est généralement bien plus petite
que le nombre lui-même.
Elle est logarithmique par rapport au nombre.
RSA1024 par exemple, a un encodage de longueur 1 024, mais le nombre lui-même est bien
sûr beaucoup plus grand que ça.
Ce schéma d'encodage fonctionne
pour les entiers non négatifs, mais si on veut traiter des
entiers arbitraires, y compris les négatifs, on
peut simplement ajouter un bit de signe.
On peut aussi permettre un nombre quelconque de zéros en tête dans ces encodages si on veut que les encodages
remplissent un bloc de bits ou un registre de taille fixe
tant qu'il est assez grand. Parfois c'est très pratique.
Ce n'est pas la seule façon d'encoder des entiers sous forme de chaînes de bits.
Il y a d'autres façons de le faire, mais c'est une façon assez
standard de le faire.
Pour d'autres types d'objets qui pourraient former les entrées ou les sorties des problèmes de calcul
qui nous intéressent, on peut trouver
d'autres schémas d'encodage.
Par exemple, réfléchis à la façon dont
tu pourrais encoder un vecteur ou un graphe sous forme de chaîne binaire ou réfléchis à la façon dont tu pourrais encoder
deux chaînes binaires en
une seule chaîne binaire en utilisant seulement le symbole zéro et un sans espace ni aucun autre symbole
pour séparer les deux chaînes. Il y a certainement des façons de
faire ces choses, et en fait, on a beaucoup de liberté
quant à exactement comment on le fait.
Souvent il n'y aura pas de façon standard unique ou universellement convenue pour encoder ce dont on parle
sous forme de chaîne binaire,
mais c'est bien, on peut juste en choisir une ou on peut en inventer une nouvelle si on préfère.
D'un point de vue purement formel, on pense aux calculs comme des transformations essentiellement mécaniques sur des chaînes de bits
et les spécificités des schémas d'encodage qu'on utilise
sont certes importantes à un certain niveau.
Mais néanmoins, lorsqu'on conçoit et
analyse des algorithmes, on ne se préoccupe généralement pas trop des spécificités des
schémas d'encodage.
Si tu demandes à deux personnes différentes de trouver une façon d'encoder, disons, des molécules d'un certain
type sous forme de chaînes binaires,
tu pourrais t'attendre à ce qu'elles trouvent des façons différentes de le faire, mais si c'étaient des personnes raisonnables qui savaient ce qu'elles faisaient,
tu pourrais aussi raisonnablement t'attendre à ce que ce soit un processus de calcul assez
simple de traduire dans les deux sens entre les deux schémas d'encodage,
nécessitant très probablement un calcul très
simple qui serait assez facile par rapport au calcul réel
qui nous intéresse.
Le fait est que les détails concernant les schémas d'encodage qu'on utilise sont souvent assez secondaires et notre attention est portée sur les
algorithmes eux-mêmes.
Rien de tout ça ne va être un problème pour cette leçon, d'ailleurs. On va principalement se concentrer sur des problèmes qui concernent des entiers, qu'on supposera encodés en binaire,
mais c'est quelque chose à savoir.
En général, quel que soit le type de problème dont on parle, la longueur d'entrée fait référence
au nombre de bits nécessaires pour encoder l'entrée,
et on considère la longueur d'entrée comme étant la taille de l'instance du problème dont on parle.
Maintenant, considérons
le calcul lui-même, qui est représenté par le
rectangle bleu dans cette figure.
La façon dont on va mesurer
le coût de ce calcul est de compter le nombre d'opérations élémentaires qu'il nécessite.
Intuitivement, une opération élémentaire est une opération impliquant un petit nombre fixe
de bits ou de qubits
qui peut être effectuée rapidement et facilement, comme calculer le ET de
deux bits, par exemple.
WEBVTT
À un niveau formel,
il y a différentes façons de définir ce qu'est une opération élémentaire, selon le
modèle de calcul qu'on utilise.
Par exemple, une opération élémentaire pourrait être une étape d'une machine de Turing si on utilisait ce modèle.
Pour les besoins de cette leçon, on va se concentrer sur les modèles de circuit, comme je l'ai déjà dit, et plus précisément sur les
quantum circuits et les Boolean circuits.
Lorsqu'on travaille avec des circuits, il est habituel de penser à chaque gate comme représentant une opération élémentaire.
On a vu plusieurs quantum gates différents jusqu'à présent dans la série,
notamment les gates X, Y et Z, les Hadamard gates, les gates S et T,
les controlled NOT gates, les swap gates, les Toffoli gates et les Fredkin gates.
On a aussi parlé des query gates dans le contexte du modèle de requête, mais on ne va pas travailler dans le modèle de requête dans cette leçon, donc on ne va pas s'inquiéter des
query gates pour l'instant.
On a aussi vu que toute opération unitaire sur n'importe quel nombre de qubits
peut être considérée comme un gate si on veut le faire.
Pour les besoins de la mesure des coûts cependant, ça ne va pas être très utile, donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va simplement
choisir un ensemble de gates
et on va considérer cet ensemble comme étant notre ensemble d'opérations élémentaires.
D'abord, on va inclure les
single qubit unitary gates que tu vois ici,
à savoir les gates X, Y et Z,
les Hadamard gates et les gates S et T, ainsi que leurs inverses
ou transposées conjuguées.
On n'a pas vraiment besoin de tous ces gates. Dès qu'on a les gates Hadamard et T, on peut implémenter les autres,
mais juste par souci de commodité, on va tous les inclure.
On va aussi inclure les controlled NOT gates, et ce seront les seuls
gates à qubits multiples dans notre ensemble.
Et enfin on va inclure les mesures dans la base standard sur un seul qubit afin de pouvoir obtenir des informations classiques
en sortie de nos circuits.
Si on se concentre uniquement sur les unitary gates et qu'on oublie les
mesures pour un instant, on obtient ce qu'on appelle
un ensemble de gates universel.
Ce que ça signifie, c'est que
toute opération unitaire sur n'importe quel nombre de qubits peut
être implémentée exactement
ou arbitrairement précisément
avec un quantum circuit construit uniquement à partir de ces gates.
En d'autres termes, c'est un
ensemble de gates suffisamment bon pour qu'on puisse construire n'importe quelle opération
unitaire à partir de ces gates.
Pas nécessairement exactement, mais on peut obtenir une approximation aussi bonne qu'on le souhaite.
Ça pourrait nécessiter beaucoup de gates, et il est en fait assez facile de raisonner que ça doit parfois nécessiter
beaucoup de gates,
mais néanmoins, c'est toujours possible.
Ce n'est pas simple de prouver que c'est un ensemble de gates universel cependant, et on ne va pas discuter de comment
c'est fait dans la série,
mais c'est un fait assez bien connu et il y a en fait différentes
façons de le prouver.
Il y a aussi d'autres ensembles de gates parfois utilisés
à la place de celui-ci, comme les Toffoli gates, les Hadamard gates et les gates S en plus des mesures,
mais c'est un choix assez standard.
Donc en résumé, ce sont
les opérations quantiques qu'on va considérer comme étant élémentaires.
Pour les Boolean circuits,
on va considérer ces quatre gates comme étant
des opérations élémentaires : les AND gates, les OR gates, les NOT gates et le FANOUT.
Le FANOUT, d'ailleurs, n'est pas
toujours compté comme un gate, mais il va être
important pour nous de le faire comme on le verra plus tard dans la leçon.
Similaire à ce qu'on avait pour
notre ensemble de gates quantiques standard, cet ensemble est un peu redondant.
On n'a pas besoin des deux AND et OR. On peut créer l'un ou l'autre en utilisant l'autre avec trois NOT gates,
mais ça ne fait pas de mal d'inclure les deux et c'est juste pratique.
Comme tu le sais peut-être déjà, c'est un ensemble de gates universel
pour les calculs déterministes, ce qui signifie que toute fonction
de bits en bits
peut être implémentée avec un Boolean circuit composé de gates de cette collection.
Encore une fois, tout comme on l'avait
pour les quantum circuits, ça ne signifie pas que toute fonction peut être implémentée efficacement
par un Boolean circuit,
et en effet la plupart des fonctions
ne peuvent être implémentées qu'avec de très grands circuits
pour la simple raison qu'il y a beaucoup et beaucoup de fonctions
et elles ne peuvent pas toutes avoir de petits circuits. Il n'y a tout simplement pas assez
de petits circuits pour tout le monde.
L'universalité est plus facile
à prouver dans ce cas que dans le cas quantique, il s'avère.
Donc si tu ne sais pas déjà
comment le prouver, réfléchis-y et
vois si tu peux le comprendre si tu en as envie.
Maintenant qu'on a décidé des
gates qu'on va autoriser et qu'on va considérer
comme des opérations élémentaires, on peut réfléchir au nombre d'entre elles
qui sont nécessaires pour effectuer
divers calculs.
Pour faire ça, on va
utiliser cette définition de la taille d'un circuit.
Cette définition fonctionne pour
les Boolean circuits et les quantum circuits et elle est très simple.
La taille d'un circuit est le
nombre total de gates qu'il contient.
Par exemple, si on revient
au même exemple qu'on a vu plusieurs fois, qui est notre Boolean circuit pour calculer le OU exclusif de deux bits,
on voit qu'il a une taille de sept
parce qu'il y a sept gates, deux FANOUT gates, deux NOT gates,
deux AND gates et un OR gate. Si on décidait de ne pas compter
les FANOUT gates, ce qui est courant, il aurait une taille égale à cinq,
mais on va compter les FANOUT gates, donc sa taille est de sept.
WEBVTT
La taille d'un circuit
correspond au nombre d'opérations élémentaires
qu'on doit effectuer.
Donc si on effectuait
ces opérations séquentiellement, la taille nous dirait
combien de temps ça prendrait,
donc tu peux penser à la taille d'un circuit comme représentant le temps d'exécution séquentiel.
C'est comme ça qu'on va
mesurer le coût de calcul pour les besoins de cette leçon.
Il y a aussi une autre propriété
des circuits qui peut également être considérée comme la quantité de temps
nécessaire pour exécuter un circuit, et c'est la profondeur du circuit.
Pour être précis, la profondeur
est le nombre maximum de gates rencontrées sur n'importe quel chemin d'un fil d'entrée à un fil de sortie,
ce qui équivaut au nombre de couches de gates qu'on doit
créer pour le circuit, où une couche fait référence à un ensemble de gates
qui pourraient être effectuées simultanément parce qu'elles n'ont
aucun fil en commun.
Par exemple, notre circuit
d'avant a une profondeur de quatre, et on peut voir directement à partir du diagramme qu'il y a quatre couches.
Les FANOUT gates peuvent être
effectuées simultanément, les NOT gates peuvent être
effectuées simultanément et les AND gates peuvent être
effectuées simultanément aussi.
Donc on peut penser à la profondeur du circuit comme représentant le temps d'exécution parallèle.
La profondeur du circuit est certainement une notion intéressante et importante et il y a des techniques très
sophistiquées qui peuvent être utilisées pour réduire
la profondeur requise pour certains calculs, parfois de façon assez spectaculaire, mais c'est un sujet avancé
et on ne va pas avoir grand-chose de plus à dire à ce sujet dans cette série.
Donc encore une fois, on va
mesurer le coût de calcul en termes de taille du circuit
ou en d'autres termes,
le nombre d'opérations élémentaires nécessaires pour effectuer un calcul.
Au début de la leçon, on a parlé du problème de
factorisation entière et on a vu que le temps requis pour qu'un algorithme résolve ce problème
peut augmenter à mesure que les entrées grandissent en longueur, et c'est généralement
le problème sur lequel on se concentre
quand on analyse des algorithmes.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est intéressés par la façon dont les coûts d'exécution des algorithmes évoluent à mesure que les entrées deviennent de plus en plus grandes.
Bien sûr, ce type d'évolution n'est pas la seule chose qui compte.
Par exemple, on pourrait simplement être intéressés à trouver les facteurs
de RSA1024 et c'est tout.
Donc dans un tel cas, on parlerait d'une
seule instance du problème où rien ne grandit.
Mais quand on pense aux algorithmes, la façon dont leurs coûts
évoluent est très importante et nous en dit beaucoup
sur les algorithmes.
Ce point de vue est
cohérent avec l'idée que les algorithmes sont fondamentaux, et comme j'en ai parlé avant,
au fil du temps et avec l'avancement de la technologie, ils seront déployés face à
des entrées de plus en plus grandes.
Mais remarque que si les entrées des problèmes de calcul
peuvent grandir en taille, les circuits ne grandissent pas.
Chaque circuit a une taille fixe.
Et pour cette raison, si on veut décrire un
algorithme à l'aide de circuits, on va en fait avoir besoin d'une famille de circuits pour faire ça,
et par famille de circuits, on entend une collection de circuits qui devient de plus en plus grande pour qu'on puisse accommoder les entrées
à mesure qu'elles deviennent de plus en plus grandes. Par exemple, considérons un algorithme déterministe classique
pour le problème de factorisation entière, peut-être un basé sur la division par essai, mais les spécificités ne sont pas vraiment importantes
pour les besoins de cet exemple.
On pourrait en principe
décrire un tel algorithme à l'aide d'une famille de Boolean circuits où si on veut factoriser un nombre
dont la représentation binaire a N bits, on prend le circuit CN de notre famille et on entre le nombre
qu'on veut factoriser
dans les bits d'entrée de ce circuit.
Parfois on pourrait choisir de paramétrer ces
circuits de différentes façons, donc il ne sera peut-être pas toujours le cas que le Nième circuit a N bits d'entrée,
mais c'est une façon assez typique de le faire. Naturellement, à mesure que les longueurs d'entrée s'allongent, on s'attendrait à ce que les circuits
de cette famille deviennent plus grands
reflétant le fait que
factoriser des nombres de quatre bits est beaucoup plus facile que factoriser des nombres de 1 024 bits, par exemple.
Et donc, dans cet esprit, on mesure le coût d'un tel
algorithme par une fonction, qui nous dit combien
d'opérations élémentaires
on a besoin pour chaque longueur d'entrée possible, et on peut faire ça pour les algorithmes classiques et quantiques.
Comme exemple, considérons le problème de l'addition entière, qui est certainement beaucoup
plus simple que la factorisation
ou même le calcul des PGCD.
Juste pour rester simples, supposons que N et
M sont des entiers non négatifs et qu'ils sont représentés
par des chaînes binaires de même longueur.
Comment pourrions-nous construire des Boolean circuits qui additionnent ces deux nombres ?
Eh bien, commençons par un algorithme, l'algorithme standard d'addition, qui est l'analogue en base deux de la méthode
que je suppose qu'on a tous apprise pour additionner des nombres avec
un crayon et une feuille de papier, donc on commence par les
bits les moins significatifs,
on les additionne, et ça nous donne le bit
le moins significatif du résultat avec un bit de retenue
qu'on doit considérer
quand on passe à la position suivante. Et on continue à travers les bits, générant des bits de sortie
avec des bits de retenue
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à la fin.
WEBVTT
Cette méthode peut être
exprimée assez directement en termes de Boolean circuits.
Une façon d'y penser est de commencer avec un petit circuit pour additionner deux entiers d'un seul bit ensemble.
Ça nous donnera un nombre
entre zéro et deux, où le bit le moins significatif est le XOR des bits d'entrée
et le bit le plus significatif, ou le bit de retenue si tu préfères, est le AND des deux bits d'entrée.
Parfois on fait référence à un circuit qui effectue ces
deux opérations ensemble comme un demi-additionneur.
Ça fonctionne bien quand il
y a juste deux bits d'entrée, mais si on veut additionner des entiers avec plus d'un bit chacun,
on va devoir traiter
les bits de retenue d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est de cascader
deux demi-additionneurs ensemble et prendre le OR des
bits de retenue qu'ils produisent pour créer ce qu'on appelle un additionneur complet,
qui est essentiellement un Boolean circuit pour additionner trois
nombres d'un seul bit ensemble.
Et une fois qu'on a un additionneur complet, on peut additionner des nombres ensemble
simplement par cascade, en allant du bit le moins significatif
au bit le plus significatif. On implémente essentiellement l'algorithme standard d'addition en utilisant les additionneurs complets pour
gérer les bits de retenue.
Donc quel est le coût de ce calcul ?
Eh bien, on a besoin de sept gates élémentaires
pour chaque XOR gate, ce qui signifie 10 gates pour un demi-additionneur
et donc 21 gates pour un additionneur complet, qui est deux demi-additionneurs plus un OR gate.
Donc en fin de compte, si nos nombres d'entrée ont tous les deux AND bits, on a besoin d'un demi-additionneur pour
le bit le moins significatif
et un additionneur complet pour chaque autre bit, et le résultat final est 21 fois N moins un plus 10, soit 21 N moins 11 gates en tout.
Si on décidait pour une raison quelconque de ne pas
compter les FANOUT gates et qu'on incluait les XOR
gates dans notre ensemble de gates, on aurait besoin de cinq N moins
trois gates en tout.
C'est bien de savoir exactement combien de gates ou d'opérations élémentaires sont nécessaires pour effectuer différents calculs,
comme on vient de le voir avec l'addition entière.
Et bien sûr, si on veut vraiment implémenter ces calculs, on a besoin de connaître ces détails.
Mais si on entre toujours dans autant de détails, surtout pour des algorithmes plus
compliqués, on sera très vite noyés dans des détails
qui dans de nombreux cas ont
une importance secondaire.
Une façon de simplifier les choses très courante dans l'
analyse des algorithmes est d'utiliser la notation grand O,
qui nous permet d'exprimer
et de comparer les taux de croissance d'une façon assez simple
qui est très pratique.
Et ici tu peux voir la définition qui sous-tend cette notation.
Supposons qu'on ait
deux fonctions G et H, qu'on peut considérer comme prenant des valeurs entières non négatives par souci de simplicité,
bien que ce ne soit pas réellement requis. Peut-être que G et H représentent les coûts de différents calculs, par exemple.
On dit alors que G est grand O de H, ce qui est traditionnellement écrit
avec un signe égal comme ça.
Si G de N est au plus une
constante positive C fois H de N, tant que N est suffisamment grand.
Donc il s'agit de ce qui
se passe quand N devient grand.
Formellement, ce que signifie suffisamment grand, c'est qu'il y a un choix de N zéro tel que l'inégalité est vraie
chaque fois que N est au moins N zéro.
La clé ici est que ces
nombres C et N zéro sont fixes.
Ils peuvent être n'importe quels nombres,
mais quels qu'ils soient, ils ne peuvent pas changer à mesure que N grandit.
Si tu n'as jamais vu ce
type de définition avant, ça peut prendre un peu de temps pour s'y habituer et tu peux trouver des ressources
qui expliqueront ce concept
avec beaucoup plus de détails
que ce que je peux faire dans cette leçon.
Ce qu'on fait habituellement c'est de choisir
la fonction H pour qu'elle soit simple afin d'exprimer quelque chose sur la rapidité à laquelle la fonction G croît.
Par exemple, la fonction dont la valeur est 17 fois N au cube moins 257
fois N au carré plus
65 537 est grand O de N au cube, et tu peux adapter cet
exemple à la définition
en choisissant C et N zéro de façon appropriée.
Par exemple, si on prend C égal à 18, alors on aura que
l'expression est en effet au plus 18 fois N au cube
tant que N est assez grand.
En reliant cette notation à l'
exemple de l'addition entière, ce qu'on peut maintenant dire c'est qu'il existe une famille de Boolean circuits
pour additionner des entiers non négatifs ensemble telle que la taille du Nième circuit, c'est-à-dire celui qui fonctionne
pour des entrées de longueur N
est grand O de N. La taille réelle de CN
selon notre analyse était 21 fois N moins 11,
mais c'est grand O de N.
Maintenant, ce n'est pas toujours judicieux de se débarrasser de détails comme ça, mais ici ça a du sens
parce que ça révèle la nature essentielle de l'algorithme d'addition standard, qui est que son coût évolue linéairement
par rapport à la taille des nombres
qu'on additionne, et cette expression n'est pas sensible à certains
détails de bas niveau de notre modèle,
comme précisément quels gates on considère comme des opérations élémentaires.
Par exemple, si on décidait que les XOR gates devraient être considérées comme
des opérations élémentaires ou que les FANOUT gates ne devraient
pas compter comme des gates, ou les deux,
on aurait quand même que l'addition entière peut être calculée à un coût grand O de N.
WEBVTT
Voici un autre exemple
de problème de calcul, la multiplication d'entiers.
Similaire à l'addition, on peut se demander quel est le coût
de ce calcul.
Si on considère l'algorithme standard
de multiplication, c'est-à-dire l'analogue en base deux de la méthode de multiplication enseignée
à l'école primaire,
qui est essentiellement un décalage et une addition quand on travaille avec des nombres en binaire, on trouve qu'il existe des Boolean circuits de taille grand O de N au carré
pour la multiplication d'entiers de N bits.
Je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails. Bien sûr les circuits sont un
peu plus compliqués que ceux pour l'addition, mais si tu réfléchis à la façon dont
fonctionne l'algorithme standard
de multiplication, ça ne devrait pas être une surprise.
En substance, on doit faire
environ N additions, chacune ayant un coût linéaire, et on finit donc par avoir
un coût quadratique au total.
Cela peut être généralisé. Si l'un des nombres a N bits et l'autre a N bits, on a besoin de circuits de
taille grand O de N fois M.
Ici, d'ailleurs, on utilise en fait une extension de la notation grand O où on a plusieurs variables, mais elle peut être étendue comme ça,
et si tu es intéressé
par les détails spécifiques, je te renvoie au contenu du manuel
pour la leçon, qui est à nouveau lié dans
la description de la vidéo.
Il est en fait possible
de multiplier deux entiers de N bits d'une façon
qui est asymptotiquement supérieure à l'algorithme de multiplication standard.
En particulier, l'algorithme de multiplication de Schönhage-Strassen
multiplie deux entiers de N bits avec un coût de grand O de
N fois la longueur de N
fois la longueur de la longueur de N. Donc à mesure que N devient grand, comme
des dizaines de milliers de bits,
c'est en fait une façon plus
efficace de multiplier, mais c'est compliqué et la surcharge le rend peu pratique
pour les petits nombres.
Alors ajoutons la multiplication
à notre liste d'exemples.
Et juste par souci de simplicité, listons le coût donné par l'algorithme de multiplication standard, qui est grand O de N au carré.
Donc encore une fois, on se concentre sur la nature essentielle de ce coût, qui est qu'il évolue de façon quadratique
ou sous-quadratique si on utilise des méthodes asymptotiquement supérieures.
On peut aussi considérer le
problème de la division entière, qui est énoncé précisément à l'écran.
On parle ici du calcul d'un quotient et d'un reste, donc la réponse consiste
en deux entiers, Q et R.
Encore une fois, il y a un algorithme standard
pour la division et il a aussi un coût quadratique et comme la multiplication,
il existe en fait des algorithmes
asymptotiquement supérieurs.
Alors comment les algorithmes de PGCD se comparent-ils ?
Eh bien, l'algorithme d'Euclide s'avère
avoir un coût quadratique, et c'est ce que je voulais dire
plus tôt dans la leçon quand j'ai dit qu'on peut calculer les PGCD
à environ le même coût que la multiplication de deux nombres ensemble.
Encore une fois, il y a des
algorithmes asymptotiquement supérieurs selon des lignes similaires à
l'addition et la multiplication,
bien que le coût soit un peu
plus élevé dans ce cas, du moins pour autant qu'on le sache.
Je vais mentionner juste un exemple de plus d'un problème à ajouter à cette liste, et c'est l'exponentiation modulaire.
Il y a ici trois nombres
d'entrée, K, M et N, et le but est de calculer
N à la puissance K modulo M,
ce qui signifie le reste
après qu'on divise par M.
Ce n'est pas du tout évident, mais on peut calculer l'exponentiation modulaire à un coût qubit, c'est-à-dire grand O de N au cube
pour des entiers de N bits.
La façon de faire celui-ci n'est pas de d'abord calculer N à la puissance K et ensuite de calculer le reste.
Même écrire N à la puissance K pourrait nécessiter exponentiellement de nombreux bits, donc cette approche ne fonctionnera pas.
Au lieu de ça, on peut utiliser un algorithme
appelé l'algorithme de la puissance, qui est aussi appelé carrés répétés où tout est fait modulo M
et on utilise les bits de
K pour mettre au carré et multiplier de façon itérative d'une façon
qui fait tout fonctionner.
Donc celui-ci est plus
coûteux que les autres, mais on peut quand même effectuer
l'exponentiation modulaire assez rapidement sur des nombres
à plusieurs milliers de bits.
Alors comment les coûts de ces tâches se comparent-ils à la factorisation entière ?
Si on commence simplement et
qu'on pense à la division par essai où on vérifie d'abord si deux est un facteur du nombre d'entrée
puis qu'on vérifie trois et ainsi de suite, on finit avec un algorithme assez
coûteux, grand O de N au carré fois
deux à la puissance N sur deux.
Chaque division prend un temps quadratique et dans le pire cas, on devra chercher des facteurs premiers jusqu'à la racine carrée du nombre d'entrée,
et c'est de là que vient N
sur deux. Si on n'a pas trouvé de
facteur premier à ce stade, on peut juste s'arrêter parce qu'alors
le nombre d'entrée lui-même doit être premier.
C'est extrêmement coûteux parce que N apparaît comme un exposant dans cette expression, ce qui veut dire que cet
algorithme a un coût exponentiel.
En revanche, tous les exemples qu'on a dans cette boîte ici ont ce qu'on appelle un coût polynomial où N est élevé à une puissance,
mais cette puissance est toujours un nombre fixe qui ne grandit pas à mesure que
la longueur d'entrée grandit.
Dans ces cas, les puissances
sont un, deux et trois.
Je vais revenir sur le coût polynomial versus exponentiel dans un instant, mais d'abord, finissons
ce qu'on sait sur la factorisation.
WEBVTT
Plus tôt j'ai mentionné
le crible algébrique des corps de nombres, qui est le meilleur
algorithme de factorisation qu'on ait en termes de la façon dont son coût évolue.
En fait, le coût de cet algorithme n'est pas rigoureusement prouvé parce qu'il est lié à certaines questions ouvertes de théorie des nombres,
mais on conjecture qu'il a
un coût qui ressemble à ça.
Cette fois le grand O est dans l'exposant, mais je vais balayer
ce détail sous le tapis.
L'essentiel à retenir est qu'il est nettement meilleur
que la division par essai parce que bien que N apparaisse dans l'exposant,
il est élevé à la puissance 1/3 et ça se traduit par un coût bien inférieur et c'est pourquoi cet algorithme
peut gérer des nombres comme RSA250, alors que la division par essai
certainement pas.
C'est quand même exponentiel dans le sens où une puissance de N apparaît dans un exposant, et donc par conséquent,
il ne peut toujours pas gérer
des nombres comme RSA1024.
Laisse-moi maintenant en dire un peu plus sur le coût polynomial
par rapport au coût exponentiel.
On dit qu'un algorithme
a un coût polynomial si son coût est grand O de N à la puissance B,
où B peut être n'importe quel nombre positif, mais la clé est que B doit être fixe, ce qui signifie qu'il ne change pas
à mesure que la longueur d'entrée N grandit.
Pour les exemples qu'on a vus il y a un instant, c'est-à-dire l'addition entière, la multiplication, la division, le calcul des PGCD
et l'exponentiation modulaire,
on avait que B était soit
un, deux ou trois.
Donc ce sont tous
des algorithmes à coût polynomial.
Mais quand on dit coût polynomial
plus généralement, B pourrait être n'importe quel nombre positif.
Il pourrait même être un million,
mais il doit être fixe.
Comme une abstraction très grossière, les algorithmes à coût polynomial
sont généralement considérés comme représentant des algorithmes efficaces.
C'est définitivement une simplification excessive, mais comme règle générale, tu peux penser à un algorithme à coût polynomial
comme utilisant d'une façon ou d'une autre
la structure d'un problème pour construire une solution plutôt qu'une approche de
force brute
ou une recherche exhaustive
sur un espace très large.
Bien sûr, un algorithme dont le coût évolue comme N à la puissance un million
sur des entrées de longueur N
ne serait pas raisonnablement
considéré comme efficace, et on ne s'attendrait pas à pouvoir
l'exécuter sur de grandes entrées.
Mais même un algorithme en N à la
puissance un million doit faire quelque chose d'astucieux qui reflète d'une façon ou d'une autre la structure
du problème qu'il résout pour éviter l'évolution exponentielle du coût qui serait associée à
une recherche exhaustive sur un large domaine.
Et en pratique, l'identification d'un algorithme à coût polynomial n'est vraiment qu'un premier
pas vers l'efficacité.
Si un problème est important
et que quelqu'un découvre le tout premier algorithme à coût polynomial
pour lui, peut-être avec un très grand exposant,
tu peux être raisonnablement sûr que les concepteurs d'algorithmes
trouveront des améliorations qui feront baisser cet exposant.
En substance, tu peux
penser à l'existence d'un algorithme à coût polynomial
pour un problème comme démontrant la faisabilité
de la résolution de ce problème
sur des entrées raisonnablement grandes, mais il pourrait encore y avoir beaucoup de travail nécessaire pour atteindre une vraie efficacité.
En théorie de la complexité, il est typique de dire que le coût d'un algorithme
évolue de façon sous-exponentielle si le coût est grand O de deux à la puissance N
à la puissance epsilon pour tout nombre réel positif epsilon, et si ce n'est pas sous-exponentiel,
alors c'est exponentiel, ou ça pourrait même être super-exponentiel comme deux à la puissance deux à la puissance N,
ce qui est doublement exponentiel,
mais tant que la sortie
n'est pas super-exponentiellement longue, tout problème peut en fait être
calculé par un Boolean circuit
à coût exponentiel il s'avère. Donc la distinction importante ici est entre le coût polynomial
et exponentiel.
On ne connaît aucun algorithme classique à coût sous-exponentiel pour
la factorisation entière.
Par exemple, le coût du crible algébrique des corps de nombres n'est pas grand O de deux à la
puissance N à l'epsilon quand epsilon est 1/3 ou moins,
donc il ne satisfait pas cette définition.
C'est sans aucun doute un algorithme très astucieux, mais c'est quand même un crible et on cherche encore effectivement
sur un très grand espace pour identifier les facteurs d'un nombre donné.
Comme on le verra dans la prochaine leçon, il y a en fait un algorithme quantique à coût polynomial
pour la factorisation entière.
L'algorithme de Shor a un coût polynomial et plus précisément il a un coût qubit, similaire à l'exponentiation modulaire.
Une autre classe de problèmes avec laquelle
tu es peut-être familier est la classe des problèmes NP-complets.
Je ne vais pas expliquer ce que sont les problèmes NP-complets dans cette leçon, mais tu peux les chercher
si tu es intéressé.
On conjecture qu'aucun
de ces problèmes n'a un coût sous-exponentiel.
C'est essentiellement une version basée sur les circuits de ce qu'on appelle parfois l'hypothèse du temps exponentiel, mais jusqu'à présent personne n'a réussi
à trouver comment la prouver.
En fait, on ne peut même pas prouver qu'il n'existe pas d'algorithmes à coût linéaire pour les problèmes NP-complets.
C'est vraiment difficile, du
moins pour autant qu'on le sache, d'exclure la possibilité
d'une future découverte d'un algorithme incroyablement créatif
pour ces problèmes.
WEBVTT
Voici une figure qui
illustre la relation entre le coût polynomial et exponentiel.
Sur l'axe X, on a la longueur d'entrée du problème auquel on pense, et l'axe Y représente le
coût de résolution de ce problème
ou tu peux y penser
comme le temps nécessaire pour résoudre le problème si tu préfères.
Un algorithme à coût exponentiel
pourrait évoluer comme ça.
Pour les entrées courtes, le coût pourrait ne pas être particulièrement élevé, comme factoriser le
nombre 12, par exemple,
mais à mesure que la longueur d'entrée s'allonge, le coût va finalement exploser.
Un algorithme à coût polynomial,
en revanche, pourrait avoir une évolution qui ressemble à ça.
Le coût augmentera quand même en général à mesure que les entrées s'allongent, et il pourrait même coûter plus cher que l'algorithme à coût exponentiel
pour certaines entrées,
mais éventuellement il va
être bien moins coûteux que l'algorithme à coût exponentiel et il n'explose pas
de la même façon extrême
que les algorithmes à coût exponentiel.
Donc si on imagine qu'on a
un coût maximum qu'on est prêts à dépenser, ou un temps maximum qu'on est prêts à attendre pour une réponse,
si tu préfères penser en termes de temps, alors l'algorithme à coût exponentiel ne fonctionnera que pour des entrées
jusqu'à une certaine longueur,
tandis qu'en général, l'
algorithme à coût polynomial nous permettra de résoudre le
problème pour des entrées plus grandes.
Et c'est pourquoi, par exemple, on peut facilement calculer les PGCD pour des nombres à plusieurs milliers de
bits, mais dans le pire cas,
on ne peut pas factoriser des nombres de cette taille.
Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va porter notre attention sur l'implémentation de calculs classiques
sur des ordinateurs quantiques.
Plus précisément, on va
voir que tout calcul pouvant être effectué par un Boolean circuit peut aussi être effectué par un quantum circuit
à peu près au même coût. De plus, cela peut être
fait d'une manière propre qui est importante si on
veut exécuter ces calculs
comme des sous-routines à l'intérieur de
plus grands calculs quantiques, et j'expliquerai ce que je veux dire par propre quand on ira plus loin dans la discussion.
On va utiliser des
Toffoli gates dans ce processus.
Rappelle-toi que les Toffoli gates sont des controlled-controlled-NOT gates, donc leur action sur les états de la base standard
est comme tu le vois ici à l'écran.
Remarque qu'on peut aussi
penser aux Toffoli gates comme étant des query gates
pour la fonction AND.
Ce n'est pas pour dire qu'ils sont des query gates au sens littéral. Comme je l'ai mentionné au début de la leçon, on ne travaille pas dans le
modèle de requête à ce stade,
mais plutôt, leur action suit le même schéma qu'un query gate.
On peut penser aux valeurs binaires A et B comme étant les entrées de la fonction AND et comme un query gate,
ces valeurs sont renvoyées
comme partie de la sortie et la valeur de la fonction, c'est-à-dire le AND logique de A et B
est appliqué par XOR sur le qubit du bas. Maintenant, on n'a pas inclus les Toffoli gates dans notre ensemble de gates standard.
On pourrait changer d'avis si on voulait, mais on n'a pas vraiment besoin de
faire ça parce qu'en alternative, on peut implémenter les Toffoli
gates en utilisant des Hadamard gates,
des gates T et T dagger
et des controlled NOT gates comme tu le vois ici.
Ce n'est pas du tout évident
que ce circuit particulier implémente un Toffoli gate, mais c'est le cas, et tu peux soit me croire sur parole
soit tout multiplier toi-même pour avoir un peu de pratique supplémentaire, ou tu peux juste demander à Qiskit ou à Python
ou à n'importe quel logiciel qui multiplie des matrices de faire la multiplication à ta place.
Et tu peux consulter le
contenu du manuel pour la leçon pour voir ça fait avec Qiskit.
Maintenant on peut passer à la simulation des Boolean gates avec des quantum circuits et tout ce dont on aura besoin
pour faire ça ce sont des NOT gates,
des controlled NOT gates et des Toffoli gates.
Ces opérations sont toutes déterministes en plus d'être unitaires et on décrit parfois
de telles opérations comme étant réversibles, et en fait,
l'étude du calcul réversible précède le calcul quantique et c'est de là que vient toute
cette procédure.
Les Boolean gates dont on doit se
préoccuper sont les NOT gates, les Hadamard gates et les FANOUT gates,
et ce qu'on va montrer c'est qu'on peut implémenter ces gates, ou les simuler si tu
préfères, en utilisant des NOT gates,
des controlled NOT gates et des Toffoli gates.
Pour être clair, ce qu'on
veut ce sont des quantum circuits qui nous permettent de calculer les valeurs des Boolean gates que je viens de mentionner
quand on leur donne des qubits dans
des états de la base standard en entrée.
Pour des entrées d'états quantiques arbitraires, l'action sera déterminée
par la linéarité comme d'habitude.
On n'a pas besoin de faire quoi que ce soit de
spécial avec les NOT gates. Les NOT gates sont des NOT gates et ils peuvent être implémentés directement.
Et les OR gates peuvent être simulés
en utilisant des Toffoli gates et des NOT gates.
Les AND gates sont faciles, surtout à la lumière de ce que je viens de dire il y a quelques instants sur les Toffoli gates étant essentiellement
des implémentations de query gate
de la fonction AND.
Pour être précis, ce qu'on peut faire c'est d'introduire un nouveau qubit initialisé à l'état zéro
et laisser ce qubit être la
cible de notre Toffoli gate et laisser les deux qubits d'entrée
être les contrôles.
Des noms différents sont donnés
à de tels qubits supplémentaires, qui sont souvent introduits
dans les calculs quantiques et je vais les appeler qubits d'espace de travail
juste pour choisir un nom.
WEBVTT
Notre hypothèse habituelle sur les qubits d'espace de travail est qu'ils commencent dans l'état zéro et on peut souvent les ramener
à l'état zéro
quand on en a terminé avec eux, mais pas toujours.
Dans le diagramme on a un ket zéro à l'intérieur du rectangle en pointillés pour indiquer que l'
initialisation de ce qubit
fait partie du processus, et si tu n'as pas
un qubit frais comme ça, tu ne vas pas être en mesure
de faire cette simulation.
Le qubit de sortie du bas
est celui qui nous intéresse parce que c'est le résultat
de l'opération AND et on en a essentiellement fini avec les deux autres
donc ils peuvent rester à l'intérieur de la boîte.
En fait, tu pourrais même imaginer que se débarrasser de ces deux qubits fait partie du travail de
simulation de ce AND gate,
un peu comme des déchets qui
doivent être nettoyés.
Mais de toute façon, c'est ainsi qu'on peut
simuler un AND gate.
Maintenant qu'on sait comment faire les AND gates, on peut faire les OR gates en utilisant
une des lois de De Morgan.
Si tu mets des NOT gates sur les deux entrées et la sortie d'un AND
gate, tu obtiendras un OR gate, donc c'est aussi simple que ça.
Et le dernier est le FANOUT, et pour celui-là, tout ce dont on
a besoin c'est un controlled NOT gate avec un qubit d'espace de travail.
Plus précisément, si on
définit le qubit d'espace de travail comme étant la cible, on copie effectivement n'importe quel état de la base standard qui entre,
ce qui agit comme un FANOUT gate.
Donc on a tous nos gates.
Et maintenant qu'on a tous nos gates, on peut passer aux circuits.
Supposons qu'on ait
un Boolean circuit nommé C, et ça peut être n'importe quel
Boolean circuit de ton choix
tant qu'il est composé de
gates AND ou NOT et FANOUT.
On va appeler T le nombre de gates dans C et on va donner le nom F à la fonction que C calcule.
Donc on peut penser à F comme ayant la forme que tu vois ici, où N est le nombre de bits d'entrée de C,
M est le nombre de bits de sortie et sigma est l'alphabet binaire.
Et ce qu'on fait c'est de simplement passer un par un à travers les gates de C.
On laisse les NOT gates tranquilles et on remplace les autres par les simulations
que je viens de décrire.
Donc si C ressemble à ça, alors ce qu'on obtient c'est un circuit
R qui ressemble à ça.
Dans ce diagramme, tous
les qubits d'espace de travail dont on a besoin pour les simulations ont été sortis de leurs boîtes et rassemblés en bas.
Donc K est le nombre total de
qubits d'espace de travail dont on a besoin, qui est un pour chacun des gates de C sauf pour les NOT gates.
Pour la sortie de R, on a les qubits qui
correspondent à la sortie de C, et ici ces qubits
sont représentés en haut,
bien qu'en réalité ça n'ait pas d'importance au final
qu'ils soient en haut ou non.
Pour être précis, en supposant qu'on a exécuté R sur un état de la base standard correspondant à une
chaîne binaire arbitraire X de N bits,
ces M qubits de sortie seront dans l'état de la base standard
correspondant à F de X.
On a aussi tous les qubits restants des AND gates et des OR gates.
On doit encore en rendre compte, et si on les rassemble tous, ils seront dans un certain état de la base standard.
Quel que soit l'état de la base standard, ça doit être une fonction de la chaîne X, et on va
appeler cette fonction G.
Donc G est une nouvelle fonction qui est
déterminée par les gates de C et qui nous dit dans quel état
ces qubits restants se trouvent
après l'exécution de R. G est la prochaine lettre après F, donc c'est une raison d'
appeler cette fonction G,
mais une autre raison de l'appeler G est que G est l'abréviation de garbage (déchets).
Ce sont tous des qubits de déchets, et en particulier, on
a deux qubits de déchets pour chaque AND gate et pour chaque OR gate.
Le nombre total de gates
qu'on a besoin est grand O de T.
C'est parce que pour chaque gate de C, on a besoin d'un nombre limité de quantum gates.
Le OR gate est le plus coûteux. Pour celui-là, on a besoin de trois NOT gates avec un seul Toffoli gate,
et un Toffoli gate nous coûte 15 gates de notre ensemble de gates standard.
Donc c'est au maximum 18 gates
dans R pour chaque gate de C.
Si tu voulais optimiser ça, tu pourrais, mais pour les besoins d'une
analyse asymptotique grossière, on peut simplement dire que
R a grand O de T gates.
Donc on a réussi à
calculer la même fonction F que le Boolean circuit original
C calculait,
et on l'a fait à un coût qui est linéaire par rapport à la taille de C.
Si tout ce qui nous importe c'est
de calculer cette fonction F, alors on a terminé.
Mais malheureusement, on a bien
ces qubits de déchets et ces qubits de déchets vont
généralement ruiner
les schémas d'interférence qui font fonctionner les algorithmes quantiques si on essaie d'utiliser ce
circuit R comme sous-routine
à l'intérieur d'un algorithme quantique plus grand.
Mais on peut en fait se
débarrasser de ces déchets, et la façon dont on peut faire ça est de faire usage du fait que le circuit R peut être inversé,
WEBVTT
ou en d'autres termes, on
peut l'exécuter en sens inverse.
Pour illustrer comment ça fonctionne, imaginons qu'on exécute d'abord R et ensuite qu'on exécute R en sens inverse,
ce qu'on peut exprimer comme R dagger.
Pour être clair à ce sujet, ça signifie qu'on applique les gates
de R dans l'ordre inverse et qu'on prend les inverses
de chacun des gates.
Les NOT gates, les controlled NOT
gates et les Toffoli gates sont en fait leurs propres inverses, donc si on pense
en termes de ces gates,
alors R dagger n'est vraiment que R avec les gates fournis
dans l'ordre inverse.
Mais en général, on peut toujours exécuter n'importe quel quantum circuit unitaire en sens inverse de la manière que je viens de décrire,
ce qui signifie qu'on applique les
gates dans l'ordre inverse et qu'on remplace chacun des
gates individuels par son inverse.
Si on faisait ça, on trouverait qu'exécuter d'abord R et ensuite exécuter R en
sens inverse ne fait absolument rien.
Donc si on commençait dans un état de la base standard comme on en a un ici, on finirait dans exactement le même état de la base standard.
Bien sûr, faire juste
ça n'est pas très utile, mais ce qu'on peut faire c'est introduire un ensemble de qubits supplémentaires et plus précisément,
ce sont M qubits où M est le nombre de bits de sortie du circuit C.
Ces qubits supplémentaires pourraient
être dans n'importe quel état quantique, mais pour expliquer comment ça fonctionne, on va supposer qu'ils sont dans un état de la base standard
correspondant à une chaîne Y. Donc Y est une chaîne de M bits, et ce qu'on peut faire c'est d'effectuer
un ensemble de controlled NOT
gates comme tu le vois ici, qui applique effectivement par XOR la chaîne F de X
sur la chaîne Y stockée
dans ces M qubits du bas.
Et donc la sortie de
l'ensemble du calcul est telle qu'elle apparaît à l'écran.
X et Y sont des chaînes binaires arbitraires. X a M bits et Y a M bits, et on a aussi besoin de K qubits d'espace de travail.
Quand on exécute R, on calcule F de X et cette chaîne est stockée
dans les M qubits du haut, mais on a aussi des
qubits de déchets,
donc on applique par XOR la sortie F de
X sur les M qubits du bas et ensuite on exécute R en sens inverse
pour nettoyer les déchets.
Je dois souligner qu'il est important que R soit déterministe.
Si ces M qubits du haut pouvaient plutôt être dans une superposition d'états de la base standard, ça ne fonctionnerait pas correctement,
mais ça fonctionne quand
R est déterministe.
Donc si on compare le quantum
circuit qu'on vient de construire au Boolean circuit original C, on voit qu'il fonctionne essentiellement
de la même façon
qu'un query gate fonctionne
pour une fonction arbitraire.
Il y a une différence ici, qui est qu'on a besoin de
ces qubits d'espace de travail pour que tout fonctionne, mais autrement on a
effectivement construit un query gate
ou un query circuit pour la fonction que C calcule.
On a aussi réussi, d'ailleurs, à ramener les qubits d'espace de travail à leur état initial, donc ils pourraient en principe être réutilisés
comme qubits d'espace de travail pour
des calculs ultérieurs.
Si on veut, on peut mettre une boîte autour de l'ensemble du quantum circuit et l'appeler Q et la relation avec
C devient plus claire.
Le circuit Q sera
plus grand que C en général. On a besoin d'une poignée de quantum
gates dans Q pour chaque gate de C,
et on a aussi besoin des controlled
NOT gates au milieu, mais le nombre est quand même
linéaire par rapport à la taille de C.
Il convient aussi de noter que c'est une procédure complètement générale qui fonctionne pour n'importe quel Boolean circuit, et on n'a pas du tout essayé d'optimiser Q.
Pour un circuit C spécifique, il pourrait très bien y avoir
des façons de réduire la taille de Q, et ça inclut l'utilisation de méthodes
qui réduisent le nombre de
qubits d'espace de travail nécessaires au cas où c'est quelque chose
qu'on veut faire, et c'est la procédure pour exécuter
des calculs classiques
sur un ordinateur quantique.
C'est assez simple, mais c'est une chose
importante à être en mesure de faire.
En particulier, maintenant qu'on
sait comment faire ça, on est libres d'utiliser n'importe quels calculs classiques qu'on veut
à l'intérieur de calculs quantiques, à condition qu'on suive cette forme où l'entrée est renvoyée et la sortie est appliquée par XOR
sur un ensemble de qubits
comme on l'avait pour les query gates.
Le coût évolue linéairement. Donc par exemple, on peut
créer des quantum circuits pour des problèmes comme l'addition entière,
la multiplication, la division, le calcul des PGCD et l'exponentiation modulaire, et tout ça peut être fait au même coût asymptotique
que pour les Boolean circuits.
On a besoin de qubits d'espace de travail pour faire ça, mais au moins ils sont disponibles pour être réutilisés à nouveau quand
on en a terminé avec eux.
Une dernière remarque qui vaut la peine d'être mentionnée est que cette méthode nous fournit une méthode pour implémenter des query gates,
ce à quoi j'ai fait allusion dans la leçon précédente.
C'est-à-dire que si on a un algorithme de requête qui prend en entrée une fonction F, et qu'on a une façon de calculer
F avec un Boolean circuit,
alors on peut suivre cette procédure pour construire un query gate pour cette fonction et ensuite exécuter notre algorithme de requête dessus.
Que ce soit utile ou non dépend du problème de requête lui-même et de ce qu'on essaie d'accomplir, mais en substance, cette
construction nous fournit
une façon de connecter le modèle de requête à un modèle de calcul plus standard.
C'est dans un certain sens comment fonctionne l'algorithme de Shor pour la factorisation entière.
WEBVTT
On va construire
des quantum circuits comme ça à partir de certaines des opérations arithmétiques dont on a parlé plus tôt dans la leçon.
Et ce faisant, on
donne aux quantum circuits la capacité d'évaluer ces opérations sur des superpositions d'états classiques.
Et comme on le verra, ça nous permet de factoriser des entiers efficacement.
C'est la fin de cette leçon, qui s'est principalement concentrée sur l'établissement d'une base
pour les algorithmes quantiques dans un cadre de calcul standard non boîte noire.
On a parlé du coût de calcul principalement à travers le prisme des problèmes liés à la théorie des nombres de base.
On a discuté du coût polynomial
par rapport au coût exponentiel pour les tâches de calcul, et on a vu comment les calculs classiques
peuvent être implémentés par des quantum circuits d'une façon propre sans déchets qui leur permet d'être utilisés comme sous-routines
à l'intérieur de calculs quantiques plus grands.
J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour la prochaine leçon où on verra comment l'algorithme de Shor met ces idées en pratique, nous permettant de factoriser
des entiers à un coût polynomial.
Au revoir jusqu'alors.